suppose suppose you want to start a
business how about a physio practice
let's do that thank you okay there's my
physio practice okay
come in and take your seats that way you
want to start a physio practice okay um
but these are practices or any
businesses really they're not cheap to
start off okay so you put together all
your savings everything you've got from
all of those little side jobs coaching
sports riffing you know that kind of
thing pull it all together okay and you
start a business okay you have the bank
you say I'd like to borrow some money
why do you think they'll say to you no
they will say no why will they say no
you got where's your where's your record
of like I've been I've been earning
money you know I've got regular income
here I have patients that kind of thing
you got nothing you've just opened your
doors right so they say forget it I'm
not giving you any money okay see like
well fine okay I'll just start a little
business with the little money that you
have you don't you rent a building maybe
you hire some staff that kind of thing
okay and um things start to go well okay
you started getting a few customers
coming in and your business is growing
and um everything's great except it's
all it's slow like if you don't have
much capital to begin with like actually
who records they have the most savings
here of anyone cuz I got credit
everyone's like no I have no savings I
are we in that I can few hundred dollars
saw that anyone go couple thousand
somewhere that yeah yeah okay all right
so that's a reasonable some money but
for a business if you if you're renting
on your building and you're hiring staff
that goes pretty quickly okay
so you think okay I can expand
I can't Smith if only I had more capital
what would you do if I if I if you have
access to more money and you arranged
this business what would you do with the
main
okay so you could do some advertising
well it's good you do come on you got
all this money matter now that you have
access to or you can pick on it's just a
bit outdated said again gray okay so you
can get rid of that dingy 20 year old
thing that you you know premium to
people's backs and get some upgrade
maybe you could get a better building
maybe you could open up like a second
location something like that okay but
you go back to the bank and they still
say no why they do that think about it
like you've been running for a little
while maybe six months so like that and
they still say you're why what you
thinking comes like at the beginning if
we did like you know we've been doing
we've been doing our graphs right if we
did income against time what do you what
would you guess that it might look like
some parts of it supplies might be
negative because it's like well we were
we had to hire people and we had to rent
the place but we weren't making that
money okay so we were going into debt
maybe sometimes you had a really good
month that was cool but then the next
month it just came down you didn't have
like a nice solid what's it what's more
client base okay so it's all over the
shop so the banks is forget it okay but
then I come along and I believe in you I
think I think you've got a great
business idea I think you've got a great
business model you don't have capital
but I do right so here's what I do I say
okay look he's uh okay there you go so I
come on and I've got my bag of cash and
I say look I you know I've been working
for a bit longer than you have so I have
access to all of this money okay so I'm
going to let you use it for a little
while but you know as you know nothing
comes for free so what do you think
might be a reasonable trade-off I'm
giving you this big sum of money what do
you think might be a reasonable thing
you might give me in return
yeah yeah okay so if you go and take my
money
and you open up a new store you shop
front hire more staff I don't know
advertise give awards that kind of thing
I expect with my biggest son big some
money right that you're gonna be able to
make more money with my monies that make
sense that's that's the point of me
giving it to you right but I want to cut
I want some percentage of your profits
okay so this is a good idea
it's a gravy for me cuz I'm gonna get
some income it's good idea for you
because you can grow your business it's
such a good idea you think hey you know
what we can do this with more than just
one person right we can do this with a
whole bunch of people we can get as many
people as we like anyone who believes in
our idea right and thinks that we've got
a good business model thinks that we can
be profitable and we can give them more
a little bit of our company and they'll
get a bit of our profits I suppose in
returns that make sense so what's
happening you've got your business right
and what you're doing is you're sort of
cutting it into pieces it's a little bit
like I've I've got this piece whatever
amount of profit like if I if I bought
twenty five percent of your company then
I'd expect twenty five percent your
profits or something like that okay now
we give these these parts a slice as we
give them names right we call them
shares okay I have a share in your
company that's the idea